HONEST TRAILER: NEW MOON
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
The continuation of the epic romance...
Between, this one hundred and nine year-old
Shovel Face...
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
... and this pathetic, codependent, girlfriend.
BELLA
"Maybe I shouldn't be dating such an old
man, its gross"
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
It really is gross.
Witness their eternal love for eachother...
EDWARD
You're my only reason to stay alive.
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
...that lasts a mere 5 minutes before she's
dumped for no reason.
EDWARD
I don't want you, you're just not good
for me.
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
Prompting his desperately obsessed ex girlfriend...
to mope around for months on end...
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
so they could do this fancy shot outside her
window.
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
Until Fish face, finds a new man to latch
on to.
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
A very, very shirtless man... with an incredibly
obvious secret...
BELLA
"So you're a werewolf?"
JACOB
"Yeah"
NARRATOR
Who is only in the movie to create a forced
love triangle for the franchise...
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
Even though they make it perfectly clear who
Dead Eyes will ultimately choose.
BELLA
"Don't make me choose. Cause it will be
him, it's always been him."
NARRATOR
A role model so, terrible and wreckless, she'll
encourage all angsty teenagers to:
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
Drive off on motorcycles with complete strangers.
Jump off cliffs.
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
Slap shirtless weird dudes.
WEREWOLF
"Rrrarr."
OTHER WEREWOLF -- O.S.
"Calm down now."
WEREWOLF
"Rrrarr."
NARRATOR
Stand between vampires and large, deadly werewolves.
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
Travel to foreign countries without telling
their parents.
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
And drown themselves to see hallucinations
of their ex-boyfriends...
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
I'm pretty sure this makes her a schizophrenic.
Prepare yourself...
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
For a movie filled with placeholder dialogue
that wasn't changed from the first draft.
BELLA
How about Face... Punch? Do you guys want
to go see... Face Punch?
ERIC
Face Punch! Remember the trailer's like,
pow pow, punch faces.
MIKE NEWTON
I, I remember.
NARRATOR
And werewolves that rip out of their clothes,
but always seem to get their shorts
back.
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
Seriously, do they keep stashes of jean shorts
hidden around the forest?
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
But when Shovel Face is in danger of flashing
children...
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
Just-Smelled-Poop-Face will ignore the months
of unnecessary turmoil he's caused
her...
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
and ride to save him on an airline that enforces
the abstinence metaphor.
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
Leading to a rushed climax that will leave
you wondering... who are these random
last minute villains?
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
TWILIGHT: NEW MOON.
Just watch True Blood instead. At least they
get naked on that show.
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
Don't forget to watch this weeks Screen
Junkies episode...
NARRATOR (CONT'D)
Where dads answer Twilight trivia for their
daughters...we made an eleven-year-old cry.